joining me now dan bongino host of the
danbongino show and fox news contributor
dan thanks for being here tonight
so uh is this willful blindness do they
think we're
morons do they really not listen to
businesses i mean
they would want the job numbers higher
you would think right
well first whose idea was it to let me
and you on the air without supervision
together this could be
serious trouble i'm just warning you in
the control room
it's true and we're in control they
can't turn it off yeah that's right get
ready to like cut to black immediately
no no seriously this is a great segment
i really enjoyed your opening
um and it just reminds me always of
liberalism
it's like sitting around a campfire
telling each other nice stories it's
like well are any of those stories real
no of course not they're not real but
they're really good stories and one of
the stories liberals like to tell each
other
which sane people like you and i just
scoff at but is now having very
real real world consequences don't worry
if we pay people a lot of money to not
go to work
they'll still go to work now most people
will thankfully we are a country of
really great entrepreneurs and
hardworking people
but the hard reality is some people
won't you know pete they have the old 80
20 rule everybody knows the 80 20 rule
and in a country of 300 million
people you know if say 20 of them say
hey i can get a nice fat check
to not do squat then i'm not going to do
squat now that's a real problem
now i appreciate ron desantis taking it
to people here and saying hey you got to
go back to work okay but i think the
republican party
needs to go really heavy on this i'm
really sorry if you can't work we
understand there's a safety net for that
there's some health problem but if you
are a capable person who can work
remove your rump from this seat and
go to work i'm really sorry there are 80
percent of the people in america who are
awesome folks
working their butts off to pour tax
dollars into this government
that's giving them to you to not work go
back to work
stop relying on the government and we
really have to be stronger with that
message cut the crap
back to work everyone back to work it's
time to get back to you
i always think about the grocery clerks
who get no praise who've worked the
entire time providing for people they
didn't have a vaccine
the teachers unions are clamoring we
can't go back even with a vaccine
there are quiet courageous hard-working
people all across this country they
deserve to be rewarded
not people rewarded to stay home is it
do you think i don't want to be cynical
here dan but
maybe the democrats are cool with people
staying at home on a government check
well we know for a long time that
they've they've wanted people
surgically attached to the government
and this is what better way to do it
than to make see here's the problem with
what they're doing now is it's not just
that simple and again it's a small
number of people
america really is a hard-working country
frankly pete it's amazing that we're
paying so many people not to work
and more people aren't working i find
that crazy
like wait let me get this straight i can
make 40k a year
to sit around and not do like why are
more people not working right
but if you're a democrat and you hate
meritocracy right
and you hate the idea that some people
who work really hard
in a great country like the united
states can get really wealthy democrats
hate that kind of stuff
what better way to equal it all out at
the bottom like margaret thatcher said
it's not a race to the top it's a race
to the bottom
then making everybody surgically
attached to the government
piggy bank and making sure they all get
the same amount of poverty at the same
time
absolutely okay dan because we have this
air time i'm going to hit you on another
another two topics here
uh one of them is this there are serious
concerns over biden's energy secretary
owning millions of dollars in stock of
an electric vehicle company that by
demonstration is actively promoting
it feels a bit like solyndra here the
media is you remember this
the media was obsessed with the two
scoops of ice cream scandal or
ivanka trump holding a can of goya beans
why is it
something like this especially when
trillions more of you know green new
deal money's going out
why doesn't this stuff get the same kind
of attention
yeah yeah this story when i read this or
they said it is unintentionally like
hilarious right
so you're you're a joe biden right you
were barack obama's vice president
you know in the portuguese plan
otherwise called the stimulus plan
sometimes
you know the solyndra thing happened
wait you also know your son hunter
has had some shady stuff going on with
ukraine china and moscow money
this is the white house you wouldn't
think someone would have sat around a
bit like
okay let's think this deal through we've
got this energy secretary
who's got some ownership in this company
and we're going to visit the company
didn't somebody at the table go
we got hunter we got solyndra this is
not a good idea
and nobody in the white house thought
this was a bad
idea this is insane speaks to their
incompetence doesn't it but also
speaks on their reliance to the media to
cover for them i mean they were like
well even if we do
it we'll probably get it away with it
for the most part all right one more in
the lightning round here dan
uh senators ron johnson you cover stuff
like this all the time better than
anybody
senators ron johnson chuck grassley
demanding answers after the washington
post i don't know conveniently found out
about their supposedly confidential fbi
briefing and used that information
to then smear the senator's report on
hunter biden is this a set up here
yeah we need a house cleaning at the top
of the fbi and we have to stop beating
around the bush around it we've seen
this tactic before
where they allegedly briefed candidate
donald trump before he was president i
say allegedly
because we now know they use the
briefing to spy on donald trump
they're doing this again now but they're
doing it's even more pernicious they
brief these two gop senators
it then leaks suspiciously to the
washington post then when the gop
senator ron johnson from wisconsin puts
out a damning report about hunter biden
the washington post then gets to write
they were warned this could have been
russian disinformation why
because the fbi briefed them what is the
fbi doing guys
i mean listen they're target lists now
pete and the fbi they're most wanted is
really bizarre
you would think it would read like
chinese counter
russian nuclear powers al qaeda their
target list now is
ron johnson chuck grassley john solomon
rudy giuliani and victoria tunsin great
dangers to the united states of america
like guys in the leadership of the fbi i
work with these guys i was a federal
agent
please get your act together the public
is losing faith you're the most powerful
law enforcement institution
on the planet get your heads out of your
butts and do your job right
what are you doing over there is there a
chance for the briefcase
all of this should have brought an
agency like that to heal
uh meaning meaning to say hey time to
rein it in
uh we only have 30 seconds but no why
would that it didn't do anything
it didn't do it you would think like all
these exposes in the deep state the
leftists
get the conspiracy theory really then
why does it keep happening by the way i
know you got to go but you have those
cool shoes those brown shoes you wear
and fox and friends
i bought those this week you did so cole
haan owes you a sale
a commissioner you go i got first i got
kill mead and now we got bongino
no you got me too i got them on right
now i'm not kidding cool shoes you're
like a fashion maven
now i feel cool for the first time all
day dan bongino
thank you brother appreciate it hey sean
hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else